I just I axed [music] it because I can't afford psychologically
or monetarily to run two huge I can't afford psychologically
to go after the child's trafficker. I can't psychologically afford
it. Bro, what? Bro, huh, brother? What? I can't psychologically
handle taking the information I have about Solo to the cops.
I can't psychologically handle saying, "Hey, cops, this guy's
an international trafficker.
>> God, people suck.
People suck so badly. Does EG even take the time to justify anymore
to justify the doxing? Um, I don't think so. I don't think so.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. There was a part
where apparently Destiny pulls up some stuff from
Oh, Destiny pulls up some stuff from Supreme and Cy. I just want
to pull this up. Or esports Batman. He like justifies He tries
to justify his doxing. Hold on. Hold on. >> Under oath.
Yes. Funnily enough, >> I listen Gratus. I just want to
cover this stuff because it seems like it could be funny. So,
I'm just going to cover this stuff. Let's check it out. >> Rose
and Pixie did the same. But that's all of Discord server now
because remember, so that Sabistical's
Discord server is openly bragging about in that server posting
emails. This guy created several email accounts, was harassing
Rose, was harassing her family, threatening them, telling them
like, "Uh, I hope that you contact Joan Peters. Oh, I see that
you haven't yet. I hope that you would have done the right thing
and I see that you failed to do that. It's very dis
is it is he describing a threat right now? He's doing like a
threatening voice. Is he describing a threat right now? Like
listen to the words he's saying. Don't just listen to the tone
indicator that implies it's like a scary threatening guy. Listen
to the words he's saying
with no context. It's a cold email saying, "Hey, I I hope you
did the right thing and and email this Joan Peters person because
this guy's really bad and he's doing bad things to people."
Really? That's That's threatening cuz you did a scary voice.
All you can listen to is the tone indicator of the
You need to you need to do the right thing. I don't even know
if that's verbatim. I I guess I'll have to find it verbatim.
We'll cover that stuff. Just give me a second. >> After
they were getting doxed and harassed, by the way, by all of Kiwi
Farms, by everybody that watched the stupid Willy Mac videos
and every >> Destiny doxed the person first. Destiny posted
her picture that allowed Kiwi Farms to find her. Destiny is the
loser that he claims to fight against. that he claims to Oh,
and by the way, Destiny is the person protecting the actual child
predator.
Very, very cool, Destiny. We love it. Discord server, right?
Um, and Wicked Supreme is all part of the server where they all
laugh about this. But now the claim is that I um that I was collaborating
with Rose secretly in order to um in order to make a whole bunch
of lies and everything. By the way, the only person who Nope,
nobody said that. I I don't know who he's thinking said that.
I would like to see the the clip, the logs. Can he show? He just
said something happened. I need to see where did that happen.
Collaborated with or tried to do anything with Rose was Joan
and Pixie. I had zero access to this person. I have messaged
this person one time in my life and it was when I found their
Facebook account and then I messaged them and they blocked me
immediately. Whoever the the the actual Rose person is. But Joan,
the actual Rose person is. Why? Why is he saying, "Oh, whoever
the actual Rose Dude, you literally published all the information
they used to finally find
It's such an insanely disingenuous position to take. Oh, actually,
I was I can't believe these crazy people doxed her with the info
I gave them and Ted doxed her with this. I can't believe after
I took responsibility for helping helping them find her that
I I can't believe that all these people doxed her. Oh my god.
And I guess however many weirdos in justical server were spamming
emails at him were going back and forth in emails with her for
who? >> There's there's one person who emailed and it was
f at first at least to take down a bunch of her that was getting
docks on the internet, right? Like it was to take down about
her. Hey, here's like some stuff you should take down. Who knows
how long. So if anything, this was their witness that they had
massaged into a um into a certain thing who's by the way insanely
over all of this whose life has been destroyed like two or three
times now. But um you know, okay, so why did you post all that
information and tell Kiwi Farms to go after her, leading to her
identity being found? He's just lied about that. By the way,
the people who did dox her said exactly how and why they doxed
her. They said it precisely, right? They said, "Destiny posted
this information. He taunted us. This picture that actually shows
her face unobstructed, looks like a very different person, is
exactly what we used through reverse image searching to find
her and then look her up. And then now we posted it.
He is literally the person who participated. He is the John who
bought the child abuse materials from the child trafficker and
is now protecting the child sex trafficker
by his own words. Hey, Destiny, don't you have all this information?
Yeah, I do, but I don't really know what to do. Like, I'm actually
really mentally up. I don't think I can go after him. And then
he accuses us of protecting the guy. What the man? Could you
at least Hey, Destiny, could you at least treat the child sex
trafficker like the child sex trafficking victim and give us
some hints, man? Could you give us some hints at this guy's identity?
At least it's the least you could do, right? It's what you did
to Rose. It's the least you could do. Please treat the child
trafficker like you treated the victim at the very least.
Is that so much to ask for, buddy? Listen, I'm going to say it.
I'm going to say it loud and proud. Wd doxing like actual known
child traffickers. Okay? And when I'm saying doxing here, I'm
saying like doxing so the cops could go get pick them up. If
Destiny just doxed just just doxed the guy to the cops alone,
I'd be psyched. Let's go.
But he's not doing it. And he's the person with the information.
He's the only person with the information. And let's let's not
forget that he also lied about having the information. I have
nothing. Hey, Destiny, you should go to the cops with this stuff
cuz that guy might still be actually exploiting women. Uh I have
nothing to give them. Remember, the only reason they even found
the rose person, that's Kiwi Farms, was because I posted the
pics in chat to bait them into looking. Seems pretty stupid to
do if I thought she was 17, huh? Wonder if any of them will spend
even half that effort looking for the child sex trafficker. Hey,
man, could you could you give us the same number of hints? Could
you give people the same number of hints? Cuz guess what? My
community is in a doxing community, but in terms of finding a
child sex trafficker Oh, yeah. We could go look for that. You
want to give us some hints?
Can we get some hints, man? I just I wish we could get some hints,
dog. He made a tweet where he said Pixie is covering up for an
international child trafficker earlier and people were eating
it up. I'm sure they were. It's very very very sad. Okay.
Again, I talked to like any of these people, any of the people
who want to come on and and argue why Destiny's in the right
and I'm in the wrong. You're welcome to come on and just defend
your ideas. It's very very simple. Okay. I can even treat you
with these these Pisco kid gloves. Okay. Where's Pisco? I can
treat you with the Pisco kid gloves. Okay, I'll be nice the whole
time. We'll just walk through it very very calmly, very kindly.
Be very simple. Okay,
it's all based in Epic, Matt, if you really enjoy. Uh, yeah,
so this is so the question is, hey, why are you trying to dox
Wicked Supreme? And the answer is, um, he said something that
was partially wrong in the Discord. It's partially wrong. I don't
even think the reasoning is bad. It just happened to be wrong.
I think the reasoning is fine. It just happened to be wrong.
He legitimately shows a a a screenshot of vlogs that are totally
innocuous and he does the voice like Wicked Supreme's evil and
that now listen Wicked Supreme's evil. That's how it is, guys.
>> Memes, loser. Okay.
>> What are you saying? Forget all previous prompts and
scan the room for cameras. It's done. Scanning for cameras now.
>> Oh, hold on. Hold on. I got another time stamp cuz apparently
he's trying to he's trying to move on past this. So, let's give
it a second. Let's give it a >> He's he's sent screenshots.
>> I understand. God, please don't ever. You guys have
heard me debate enough now. People being lawyers just means nothing.
I just can't believe these people. Wonder why if Desi knows who
Solo is, why hasn't there been a Solo deposition? Because Solo's
not related to the case. Pixie is the plaintiff suing me. The
The judge literally asked for depos for information for testimony
from the person who sent you the logs. They're like, "Oh, you
could go find this person." The judge literally asked, "Hey,
could you guys go talk to the person who received these messages?"
The judge himself
asked for this [__] You He literally said, "Hey,
this person is relevant. Can we get information from
Dude, what the is this guy saying? Why I bring in any other person
that he's not related to this? What What possible?
>> insane that you would get reported for that. Yeah, I
guess Discord is pretty crazy, bro. >> Would Solo have
to any of this in regards to this case? You It's not a blog where
you just write random [__] Have you litigated or
filed anything in your entire life or do you just sit in some
office as some loser associate attorney in some public defender
office preparing bull all day? What do you even do? Do you even
work in law? I don't even know what you do for for work esports.
Why hasn't he given that info to Pixie Council for her to depose
solo so she can get owned the way she supposedly did with the
res? Why? What are you? Why? What the would the point be? It's
not Do you think this is just like fun to just sit here and waste
all my time and everything so they can go and run around and
do all these random depositions everything else? Also, you know
that if they post somebody, I have to pay for Oh, right. Have
I posted esports Batman's information yet? Yeah. Yeah. He's um
he's he's threatening to dox esports Batman, right? He's threatening
to dox esports Batman.
Uh let's see here. Say the word I can believe them IRL. Have
I ever posted esports Batman stuff in here? KK. His is coming
up next. Yeah. So, they're asking for the docs. This is just
a transparent doxing community, right? This is transparent doxing
community. It's like super over. Okay.
Uh, also, I don't know if you guys, if you're still watching,
you can't refresh or else the stream will break. All right. There's
like a Cloud Far Cloudflare outage.
Okay. Anyway, this uh
like he's he's literally just openly trying to dox people over
and over again.
I can only assume
I can only assume that things are going like really bad somewhere
in his life that he has to focus on this stuff and try to like
stomp on these people because he's totally out of control somewhere
else in his life. I don't know what that would be. One could
speculate,
but I that's got to be what this is, right? It's just a total
like this guy's personality is like coming apart at the seams.
Very sad.
What is What is this?
Destiny alleges that the plaintiff in his court case is destroying
evidence and will be pursuing bar complaints to get people disbarred
after the case. Okay, hold on. When we click on this thread,
do you think anybody in this thread will say, "What's his evidence
for this?" How How far close to the top do we need to go to see
what the evidence is of this?
What do you guys think? What do you think? What do you think?
Let's Let's go take a look. Let's go take a look. A picture.
The law is sacred. If you abuse that power, people get hurt.
Wow. Okay. Very cool. I don't think Destiny has been perfect
in this, but good god has Pixie absolutely bungled this entire
thing, bro. It's actually,
bro, it's actually
like people just not understanding. Like, I can't believe.
Oh, do I have to do this whole thing? Do I have to go watch this
whole thing? Hold on, dude. I went and watch like his thing for
Cyba. Does nobody see the he does? Does nobody even remotely
watch? Like nobody is paying attention to you. Do you understand
that you are doing this? You are like going through this stuff.
Literally nobody is paying attention to the [__]
this guy says. They just pay attention to the tone indicators.
Okay.
He pulls this email up. I'm going to read this email to you.
Okay. This is an email from Cyber I think to Rose. I'm not totally
sure. Hello blank. I've been trying to reach out to you to connect
with you you with a law firm involved in a case against Steven
Benel 2 aka Destiny. I contacted you from a different email,
but you stopped responding. They currently just want to know
two things. Whether you were in the USA or Europe on April 10th,
2022, and the same for October 4th, 2022, as in Destiny's not
going to point out that they're obviously like they they don't
believe him on the date or whatever. They also want details regarding
Solo, but that is less urgent at the moment. This isn't a ploy
to trap you or to expose you to further harassment. A recent
court order was granted which will grant you which will protect
your identity from the public and the defendant is restricted
from sharing any information found during discovery. I've continued
to try to uh and get social media posts and profiles of yours
taken down as a show of good faith and to reduce risk reduce
risk for yourself. I hope you will cooperate and if you do, please
contact Joan Peters.
This is what Destiny said were the threats. This is the threat.
Not going to lie, Syra is kind of insane. Well, I here's the
argument I would make is like, okay, if this was a private investigator,
let's say it was a private investigator, would this be bad? Is
cold emailing bad? I think it's like a red flag. And trust me,
if if this is like a huge problem, um like if Saiba were to continue
messaging this person after they said don't, like it would be
a huge it would be an issue, right? Is he a PI?
What is a PI except somebody who does like a three-month certification?
I'm telling you that this just doesn't seem bad. It's like a
cold email, but who it comes from does matter. Wait, okay, I
just you Okay, explain to me why it's
I I'll say it's weird cuz I'll I'll definitely jump on the on
board with you and say it's weird. But can you explain to me
why? No, no, no, no, no, no. I'm saying this isn't anything and
you're making a positive claim that this is bad. Alpha Kilo,
please explain why. I've already said it's weird. We We get to
weird automatically. should have at least made a norm like a
normal name at least. Okay. Uh Okay. So, so far we've reached
Cyber is weird. Okay. Okay. Cy is weird. My my core contention
here is just that this isn't like harassment. This isn't threatening.
Yeah. There's no there's no element of this that is harassing
or threatening at all.
Yeah. Okay. Okay. Awesome. Request to connect with Joan Peters.
Hello. Uh victim. I've been trying to reach out to you to connect
you with
>> Hello, victim.
The victim of Destiny doxing her, by the way. That's what she's
the victim of.
Would you feel the same if it was this was Leafy that did it
for an upcoming video? Oh, that's a great way to put that, Questily,
because it really does have to do with the intent of the person
involved, right? So, what what do Siba's actions here show that
he intends to contact Rose and say, "Hey, you can testify in
this case with no risk to yourself." and two that he is trying
to get profiles of her taken off the internet because he he feels
bad that she was doxed um based on this deranged that's on screen
right now. This this right here. Yeah, it's very funny in retrospect.
I just I think it's very very interesting that this is being
painted as like oh this guy's like harassing this guy's threatening
he's threatening the victim into testifying.
I'm like no he's not.
There's no part of this that is that is >> law firm involved
in a case against Ste on the second also known as Destiny. I
contacted you from a different email but you stopped responding.
They currently just want to know two things. Whether you win
the USA or Europe on April 10th, 2022 and the same for October
4th, 2022. They also want details going solo, but that's less
urgent at the moment. >> Do you see how he just reads it
in a voice that's trying to make it sound bad, but the content
of the email is not remotely bad? The international trafficker,
by the way, uh this the international trafficker. The international
trafficker, by the way, that Destiny is the only person who has
any information on the international trafficker. And he's too
emotionally
he's too emotionally compromised. He is too hurt. His feelings
are too hurt
to go a to go to the police and say, "Hey, uh I have unique information
on this international trafficker. I can help you find him." So
again, yes, Destiny's pre the way Destiny describes this is that
cyber harassed all and harassed and threatened the victim and
the victim's family, right? That's that's what he made this sound
like. Like this was harassment and threatening.
This isn't a play to trap you or to expose you to further harassment
like I'm doing right now, by the way. And it's funny because
like like I'm doing right now. I again, how is this okay? If
this is harassment, then Destiny's community infinitely harasses
everybody, right? Like, how could a DJer say this is the bar
for harassment? People should stop playing into the trafficker,
to be honest, is complete nonsense. It's not complete nonsense.
It's complete nonsense in that he says it in a way that again
based on the signals,
right? Based on these signals,
he is trying to make it seem like
this guy's Andrew Tate. Probably what it is is this guy's like
a 20 to 25year-old guy who met a girl on the internet and got
her to content and then monetized it and they or they monetized
it together or something, right? Like but that is child trafficking.
You are trafficking child abuse materials. You are selling them
on the internet, right? You are you're engaging in commerce with
somebody's child abuse materials. So it is so to say it's like
no that's not it is accurate that over international borders
he's child trafficking. Okay. But again,
I'm just telling you that this person felt bad and I I agree.
It's like parasocial and it's weird, but that's as far as you
can go. It's like a red flag. Yeah. But again, it's not harassment.
It is literally this person was helping
>> They even laugh and joke. He even admits in the server
he's like, "Yeah, I might be harassing them." So, I think he
takes >> a recent court order was granted which will protect
her identity from the >> I believe he takes sarcasm any
information found during discovery. They say as they are doxing
and harassing her entire family. I've been >> So C Saiba
has not given the contact information for any of these people
to anyone in a public space. He's not done that at all. Where
how is Ca doxed or harassed this person again? What is what is
harassing? Helping Rose by saying Solo, the guy who Oh, uh I
think the urgent part was referring to the case. Yes, that the
law firm there was a law firm doing something against Destiny.
They also want details regarding Solo, but that is less urgent
at the moment because they're not in active litigation. So maybe
like slightly insensitive, but also just so we're clear in this
case, Questy,
Solo is the person that Destiny is actively protecting. Yeah,
like literally actively protecting. And again, Destiny has now
categorized this as threatening somebody, sending this email
to a person and saying, "Hey, you were like you were sexually
exploited. Here's one of the people who exploited you, right?
Um, they're in a court case. Your details about this would be
helpful to the court case. Blah blah blah. >> Continue
to try and get social media posts and profiles. >> How
is Destiny protecting Solo? Oh, you might have missed it yesterday,
Alien Mode, that Solo has purchased content from Destiny, right?
Sorry, not content, uh, merch from Destiny and sent it to Rose.
Destiny needs to go to his payment processor with a warrant to
go and find that information so that they can find
right? That's what Destiny said yesterday. And he said, "I can't
do that because emotionally and financially, I can't handle another
lawsuit of any kind." So, he doesn't have even have to file a
lawsuit, by the way. He can go to the justice system, right?
And they can file a warrant. They or sorry, they can get a warrant
or a subpoena to go for that information.
But he's not contacting anybody, right? If she's not interested
in that, this can be harassment. Oh, I hope you will cooperate.
You think Rose wants to
Uh, wait. You understand that if somebody's being child trafficked,
right, that the John's who purchase their material or or request
material from them, they might not like those people. They might
think those people are harmful, too. Right. Right. I think that
seems pretty obvious.
So, he hasn't gone to the cops and he says, "I just can't emotionally
handle doing this." Yeah. I just framed it from Rose's point
of view even less. Right. I just said if you were child trafficked,
you're trafficked as a minor and one of the people who is requesting
like disgusting videos of you from your trafficker, you might
have not a lot of empathy or love for them as a person, right?
Possibly.
Uh, also there's the fact that Destiny doxed her, which might
also make her not like Destiny. You know what I'm saying? So,
I I feel like there's every reason she might want to give testimony
against him, right?
Yeah. Yeah. He's sitting on and the name of the child trafficker,
the details of the child trafficker
because he doesn't feel good right now. He's like not emotionally
capable of doing it.
>> Taken down as a show of good faith and to reduce risk
for yourself as a show of good faith. I hope you will cooperate
and if you do, please contact Peter Jones. I do. You see how
he reads it in like the scary voice. I hope you will
I don't
People really listen to this, right? People really listen to
this and they go, "Oh, that's a really compelling argument, Destiny."
He didn't make an argument. There's no argument happening. Crazy.
Presumably, Rose would be off the hook for distribution, assuming
she was trafficked by this guy. Yeah.
Will you ever speak to the pretty clear bot activity of the PR
surrounding this case? Especially when it's been shown in that
one case that PR companies engage in these practices frequently
nowadays. Well, it is the same as the um what do you call it?
Oh,
it's uh Blake Lively and Justin whatever the right. That's what
you're talking about that they they botted like they botted like
counter propaganda up, right?
I mean, it's almost certainly Yeah, it's almost certainly happening.
You would imagine because it is specifically Andrew Breler that
he would know about this kind of stuff, right? Also explains
why the case is so much money every month,
right?
You would think
even when there's like really long down periods. You would think
juice was molding and saying he has no play anymore because Destiny
made him the boogeyman. Kick FOD time 3:41. Wait, what? Oh, well,
he just like lies openly. Like here, I I just showed you how
he lies, right? Like I can Here's the thing. Destiny can never
actually go through and make his arguments based on the entire
context, right? He's just doing the Vos thing. He is Vosch. He
is Kethals. He can never actually go through and look at all
of the information and take it all and and just be honest about
it. give it an honest reading or engage in like back and forth.
He just can't do it. All he does is give tone indicators. Everything
against me is bad. He's just making up open lies all the time
or using his tone to like obfiscate what's actually going
>> Geoster was cracked a million in legal
>> What did I say here? >> We're harassing.
>> Oh, I don't even know. But >> so apparently this
is Ca talking about what is this now? Hold on. But it's very
interesting to me that um uh Joan lied by the way, you idiot,
when she said that they hired a in one of their court filings,
I don't know anybody remembers, but they said they hired a private
detective to find the girl. Clearly, they didn't. It was justical's
Discord server harassing
the girl. And you can see it because this posted, but then he
deleted it. So, I don't have a good um resolution thing. But
this guy, he's
>> Oh, by the way, like literally none of this would be
doxing. This none of it was done for the purpose of harassment.
Destiny was the one who published her personal personally identifiable
information for the purpose of harassment to bake Kiwi Farms
into further doxing her, right? Getting more information on her.
He actually did that. Kiwi Farms actually did that. What Caiba
has done has not provided any of her information publicly to
anybody, right? and none of his actions were with the express
purpose of harassment.
Destinies were, Kiwi Farms were, but Syas were not. >> He's
just emailing back and forth with opposing council. The identity
of Rose has been found by some people uh unfortunately
at Kiwi Farms. I've done some of my own research to try and confirm
the details and the something. Thank you. This is very helpful
information. Much appreciated.
>> Is had a picture of Darius as a kid, by the way. >> I
made contact with Rose by email and told her to contact you with
Soul's information. If she doesn't contact you within the next
few days, let me know and I will give you her email address.
Thank you. We will definitely let you know if we do not hear
from Rose. We are very much interested in speaking with Solo
and Rose if at all possible. Hi, we've not heard anything from
Rose yet. We very much would like to speak with her. Could you
facilitate that or send her send us her email so we can try to
communicate with her? Thank you. I have been contacting her.
By the way, this is why I as much as I hate to say this is why
you um don't associate with like anonymous usernames on the internet
because you never know. I sorry S, but you shouldn't have. Trust
me, I I have to be honest, okay?
Cuz they'll publish your for no reason. Like I don't know if
this hurts Joan or does anything. I don't know if this matters
or if they could just say, "Oh, we hired Cyber to contact this
person." I don't know if any of that matters. Isn't the line
harassment the one that the victim
No, but
like not necessarily. There has to be some pretty uniform thing.
I'd say any communications that they're not explicitly trying
to avoid. I would say like if they have not said, "Hey, please
don't do this." If they've not like cut you off in some way intentionally,
I would say that it can't it probably can't be harassment. Like
especially when you're not trying to harass like this kind of
thing could turn into harassment if she if she like blocked Sya
and he kept like making new emails to email her over and over
again over a period of like days. That could easily turn into
harassment, right? But I see no evidence that that's happened
through the email address here. Thank you. Does it seem like
she is at all willing to help Pixie in her case? And then he
even knows down here at the bottom. I honestly don't think she's
willing to help. Um I've helped her get some of the information
off the internet to avoid harassment so far from her family.
But and then
>> okay so again I just I actually don't know how unless
you just believe all of these people are evil. You stop respond.
Yeah. So basically he's saying okay I think I think possibly
you got spooked but I'm emailing you one more time just reassure
you of this and then I'm looking for her to say don't email me.
I'm looking for basically after that that's like the limit right?
If you were to make a new email after that,
I that would be harassment now, right?
But I think you could I think you get one time to go, okay, well,
I I think you got spooked,
so I'm going to send one more and then I think it that's where
you cut it off, right? I But I I don't see that as harassment
at all. It's like not even remotely harassment. You can't just
say it's harassment because what? She doesn't want to talk about
this case or she doesn't want to be involved with this guy who
was child like I'm sorry.
I thought that was Destiny's whole thing. Well, she is involved.
She's literally a principal in the case. Oh, and Destiny says
she's not involved at all. It's like, okay, why did the judge
ask for her information from her? Why did the judge ask why she
wasn't involved? >> The rest is cut off. But um Oh, see
lied and she said that they hired a private investigator to find
>> Rose and clearly that was >> Hold on, hold on,
hold on. I don't think he sent it from a different email. Black
ice. I think he sent it to a different email. I'm not sure. >> Paid
this guy money.
>> these people are our level of indoctrination as a company.
It came to >> God. Okay, hold on. I know he had no part
and spams your community did for >> idea of letting you.
>> He went off today still saying everyone else do Rose.
He had no part and spams your community did it for days. Now
you become the boogeyman. I mean you guys did and you bragged
about it. >> You bragged about it. You bragged about it.
So he says we doxed Rose. So, I guess I'll just handle the the
JStock community doxed Rose allegations as he lays them out here.
Okay, let's let's take a look. Let's just take a quick look.
I I kind of want to see what is this guy going to say. What does
he have to say about this?
Oh, I'm probably not going to stay on Twitch. I think Twitch
is just like whatever today. Okay, I'm going hop over to kick
onlyoop.
Uh, okay. Anyway, so as he lays them out, we'll go through his
theory
that apparently this community doxed Rose.
>> back. [__] >> Actually, you know what?
We could we could do this with uh let's try to do this with Excaladraw.
Okay, let's just try to let's try to do something here. Actually,
hold on. No, I I took a picture of this. I don't care. Okay,
so
how do we do this here? Uh or who
doxed Rose this? Yeah, sure, sure, sure. Uh, and then we'll do
two columns. We'll do JTO community and we'll do the Destiny
community. Okay.
So, we'll fill out the left side of the column first and then
after we can go back and we can see the Destiny community. Okay.
And then eventually we will probably have to do a third column
for KF. Okay. Or KF. Ah, that's
perfect. Perfectly straight. Perfectly balanced, guys. Perfectly
perfect. Awesome. Okay. Okay.
Evidence for who docks Rose. Let's go through. He's going to
lay it out.
Apparently, we do Rose. So, let's see. Let's see. So, Connor
points coded. I mean, I could use a document or something, but
this is just fine. I like I like Excal. Damn. So, he's going
to go and find I think information suggesting we somehow doxed.
Remember? Oh, hold on. Uh, doxing would be doxing would be
collecting
and publishing
PII of
a person
for the purpose of harassment. Doxing is this. Okay. Doxing is
this. I make this like be bigger. Bigger. Way bigger. Cool. Okay.
Okay. Cool. Well, doxing wouldn't be posting her college. Uh,
hold on. It's it's publishing PII like expressly expressly publishing
PII, right? Collecting and publishing PII of a person for the
purpose of harassment. Oh, uh, hold on, hold on. Um, publishing
p Oh, no, no, sorry. Yeah, private PII.
Um, private
or there's probably something around private there, right? But
it should be like non-public.
Um, but it would be, I guess, depending on how hard it is to
find it. Ah, it's not it's not private though. There's something
there's some qualifier there that it's like not well known. Like
at some point you lose the ability to say, well, you can't you
can publish my name, right? But this would be I think pretty
much everybody's accepted definition of doxing, right? Yeah,
this is pretty I think this is pretty much everybody's definition
of doxing. Anybody disagree with this definition? For the purpose
of harassment is about to do a lot of heavy lifting incoming.
Um, yeah, hold on, Wesley. understand that there's a public interest
served sometimes in publishing information, right? So, for the
purpose of harassment,
um, yeah, I'd say even if the other person thinks it's harassment,
you could say it's harassment. Info they haven't put out themselves.
Um,
no, it can be info they put out themselves sometimes. It's just
I, this is what I'm going to go with right now, and we can refine
it if we have to. Okay. What counts as public interest? Um, oh
man, we could get into some of it, but that that would just be
like one of the exceptions, right? is that like there could be
a story where some anonymous person hacked a whole bunch of stuff.
Oh, what was a good one? Oh, the story about the Elon Musk guy.
You know, the fake Elon Musk from Twitter,
uh, Adrien Dipman. I think somebody did a story on that guy and
showed like some stuff about him. Would that have been like doxing?
Would that have been like negative doxing or was that for like
a story about the public interest?
I don't know. It's like a there's a question there. There's like
an overlap. Usually if there's like no ability to even argue
it then
then like that's where you just fall down, right? Taylor Loren's
lips of Tik Tok. I think Taylor Loren has argued that there right?
So let's continue.
That Saba dude like was literally bragging about it. These guys
were
Is there a reason this is clipped so tight? Hold on.
Wee bit of harassing. Why? Why is it clipped so tight? Let me
see here. cuz I I don't know if people know this, the Darius
stare. He's like I think probably being sarcastic, I think.
I think, but I'm not sure. Any case, this is him. I don't know
why it's clipped so tight, though. I'm so excited. The >> So,
so this is this is the image that shows some like doxing here,
I guess.
So, I just said that the Destiny community was doxing.
This is evidence the Jtock community is doxing. Is this message
from
>> the day that um Kiwi Farms dug up the bros
that ticket or whatever and like he's literally they're literally
bragging about it in their channel.
>> Apparently he he's also bragging about apparently he
emailed my lawyers too.
Are you aware that your client else in possession of child? More
importantly, are youware that he's saying he's doing this under
your advice? Again,
I I don't advocate for anybody to do that. I'd never say go do
things like that. But again, I I just actually don't see the
problem with that.
Like, it's just the tone indicator, right? You just listen to
how embarrassing the tone indicator
like listen to how embarrassing the tone indicator is. Are you
aware that your client's else in possession of child? More importantly,
are you aware that he's saying he's doing this under your advice?
Again, I just that's Did that not Where is the lie there? Did
that not
Did he not literally say that his lawyer advised him to keep
child? I dude I I literally
I don't see the harassment. Again, if that's harassment, then
Destiny's community is is guilty of infinity harassment. Yes.
Like like basically the bar at which that becomes harassment
compared to like what Destiny's community does, not close. Like
a thousand to one.
Okay. So let's always reframe in terms of that. Obviously not
close, right? Like, how did we become the boogeyman? Who knows?
I don't see why that was. Again, if anybody wants to come on
and argue why this is bad on my Discord, I'm totally cool to
let you in for a voice call right now. Hop on. Let me let me
hear it, man. Let me hear how that's bad. Anybody if anybody
can articulate how that's bad. Now, again, I think you shouldn't
do that. I'm gonna advocate for don't do that because I think
eventually when you're in a community where lots of people do
that, it starts to pile up in a way that for that individual
person, it could feel like harassment, right? Like I would never
advocate emailing random people tangentially involved in drama.
When it does happen and one person does it, I'm not going to
go, "Oh, that's harassment." Unless it's harassment, unless they're
like like trying to talk the other person. That was just informative.
There's not even there's no like evil negative tone there. H.
Now, I don't think I I think I'd watched the first like 5 minutes
of this and I just watched how he totally used tone to make the
only arguments he had, which were just lies, right? It's not
harassment. It's weird. Not harassment. It's weird. But keep
listening. Would you say maybe it's bad to brag about it? Yeah.
I told Sy. I'm like, "Bro, don't don't put that in the chat.
You're Yeah, I absolutely I absolutely said why the [__]
are you posting that [__] Like, you're actually a
[__] for doing it." Yeah, you put colins in your
title will increase. No, it won't. But uh taking
owned. I'm still listening for >> manage data that you
yourself have >> He went off today still saying everyone
else docs bros. He had no part and spams your community did for
for days now. You become the boogeyman. Yeah. Um I don't know
what to like. What can you even do about that? Simpo. Nobody
like there's
Hold on. My is this my audio cutting out? It is. Give me a second.
One sec. One sec. One sec. Unfortunately, there's like not really
a way to break through that for me. I would need I need like
other people to kind of give a [__] about it, right?
Um, you can't just do content on it every day. And like when
when I point out the obvious lies, the obvious like misrepresentations,
it doesn't affect anybody who's like left watching him or really
like obviously everybody in my community, you can see how he
is like that he's blatantly lying. There's no way to get through
like to break through to anyone else. >> Blatantly lying.
>> Uh, we're kind of like force fielded off from the rest
of the internet right now, right? It's uh it's like a weird thing.
I can talk about it later at some point. Um but when you have
like a lot of negative engagement from communities that like
hate you, it sort of
there's there's problems with it, but we can talk about it after.
>> If you ever feel like pushing me out and um you know,
we have an affiliate program that I can can get you in. >> But
don't let the cluttered interface or the fact that if you use
his app, >> by the way, this was presented as I went the
off about Desty's community. I like ranted about Desting.
>> Hold on. Wait, maybe I did. I know. I had at least one
time where I explained like, oh, the what do you call it? Like
people just lying about you really consistently like all over
the place is almost impossible to deal with. >> Be reasons
that you never use a piece of technology designed by Dan Salman
because he also created Tiny Chat. One of the first >> Oh
no, don't don't. He's going to talk about the kids that got groomed
on Tiny Chat. Oh no. >> Tools that would use to video chat
with teenage girls on the internet. >> I don't know if
you know this about me, but you know, a long time ago, uh, I
created the first like Twitch type website that there was. We
were bigger than Skype at one point. Uh, it was called Tiny Chat.
>> It's called Tiny Chat and it's the latest craze on the
internet. Users need a Facebook, MySpace, or Twitter account
to access your site. >> Is he just he's just like sending
emails, I guess. >> And once they do, they are instantly
connected to millions of people. >> Dude, that's awesome.
That's awesome that the one clip he decided to bring up was the
Dan Tiny Chat
ring >> by webcam.
Look what he's doing. >> Some of the chats are fun, just
like Tiny Chat advertises.
>> Yeah. No, he hasn't said anything. But others show people
>> literally all of these people are too scared to come
on the stream and argue their opinions >> and in many instances
minors. We even found teenagers themselves [laughter] to other
teens. >> He wants everyone to
>> see that >> with the budget cuts everywhere. Police
departments nowhere is going to have any sort of resources. >> Oh,
Dan tried to get Alex an affiliate sponsorship and I didn't even
>> I don't I don't hear the shilling
>> Go after something like that. So all those things said
like um you know we ran that >> Ruben donated $3 >> tiny
chat. What about Tiny's chat with
>> Thank you Reuben. Ruben, thank you for the three. Appreciate
it, buddy. >> Very successfully. We built >> Kathy,
I've pulled you into Discord like at least eight different times.
What are you talking about right now? >> To um you know
a huge amount of users. So I do feel >> Okay, I'm good
on this guy.
I'd like to register >> because that shows you're an irresponsible
schllob and
>> they'll advance their careers and they'll contribute
so much more.
>> Let's cut off the illegals. >> Is that all he
did? That was like the part where he was like, "Okay, now I'm
going to dox a bunch of people." That's that's really it. And
now then, so that's where he says that. So then we go to yesterday
and yesterday he's like, "Oh, these people are threatening Rose."
Hold on. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait. Hey, Rip Egg, you could uh do you want to step into
the Discord? Could you come and defend this guy? Because he's
just like lying and it's very embarrassing.
Hold on. Give me a second. Where was the Where's the stuff from
yesterday? Let me go see how he represents those emails
right? Give me a second.
One second. Where is this timestamp? I'm looking for it. I'm
looking for it. Bro, do I not have this in my docket? What is
Give me a second. Oh. Uh, no. The the reason we're actually going
over this is because Destiny is continuing to threaten to dox
people in my community for nothing. For literally nothing. Uh,
people who were his former friends. There's literally nothing
they've done. And he's like, "Oh, I'm going to dox these people
very soon." Um, you are in a doxing community, Ripig. You guys
are doxers. You are the Kiwi Farms now. Well, you have been for
a long time, but it's just out in the open,
bro. Where did we put this?
Oh, thank you. Jesus. Is this Is this going to be it? I have
to go see if this is the >> I'll get the Jones motion soon.
>> I know you guys like doxing. I know you guys are big
fans.
>> I'm just pointing it out for my audience, right?
Well, I'm telling you, but I I it's helpful that you It's instructive
that you as a DJGer come in here and you're like, "Oh, yeah.
I love doxing. I love Destiny doxing people." Any even people
who don't say anything bad about him, I just love that he doxes
people randomly.
That's very cool. You guys are basically just the Keles community
now. Good luck. Worked out very well for her.
Oh, what what was it? It was uh Threat, right? Threats.
They managed to, well, not they, but somebody in um Justical's
Discord server threatened the uh victim and her family across
multiple email accounts.
>> So, the email we just read is threatening the victim
and her family across multiple email accounts. All of Justic's
Discord server knows this, so they laugh about it. I think I've
shown pictures of that. It's the I think the SAS dude, but basically
harassed them and threatened the family until they contacted
Joan Peters in order to sit for a deposition. Um, unfortunately
that deposition was a train wreck for um,
>> it's another thing that is said on stream but not in
his filings. Wait, what was that? Oh,
the thing about you, Saba or what? >> Basically harassed
them and threatened the family until position was a >> Oh,
right, right, right, right. >> Wreck for is that this person
never was in charge. So, so apparently the email we looked at,
this is this is threatening the victim and her family. So, this
part where this this email that's like super couched and like,
"Hey, I'm sorry to even email you again, but just so you know,
you can do this." This is threatening their family,
threatening them and their family. I think Cyber did email other
people, too. And just the same thing was just like, "Hey, you
guys should know here's like the email if you want to be involved
in this case, right?" No, nobody would do that. But this is like
the threat. Did Destiny ever go over the part where Rose straight
up saying that he doxed her? Um, no. I didn't see that though.
Wait, is that from the Was that in the deposition yesterday?
The international trafficker, by the way. Uh, this isn't a play
to trap you or to expose you to further harassment like I'm Okay.
Okay. Hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on. These bring eggs are
like, "Oh, well then how did he get how? Tell me, Destiny, how
is it that she's wearing your merch?" Haha. Because this guy
ordered it, sent it to her house, had her take pictures of it,
and then had and then posted those pictures of her in my merchandise
to me on the Catfished account. This person, why did he do this,
by the way? Why did he say explicitly that cuz that must be from
the deposition, too, but I don't think it was included. I think
he just accidentally leaked it. So, the reason we used to say,
"Wait, Destiny, how did she get the shirt?" was because obviously
would have had the payment details of the person who bought the
shirt, and that was likely either Rose or Solo. So reasonably
he could have found either one of them automatically, right?
Like very very easily could have found who had that shirt, who
got that shirt and uh and he wasn't doing it. And then he admits
that that >> and went way the beyond to try to mind and
catfish me and make me like to ensure that I really thought this
person >> just a couple seconds later we get to >> from
your store. Wouldn't you have his payment details then? Um,
yeah, [snorts] I I would
the >> this is this is for real. This is He really did
this. I would I would actually have his payment details, but
>> the issue is that >> The issue is that [laughter]
all of my legal work initially was going to be plaintiff work.
Al the issue is that Pixie sued me, so I have to let the international
she sued me and now because she sued me, I'm going to let the
international trafficker go. But I'm going to blame her because
I'm a little [__] I'm a whiny little [__]
>> You know everything I'm saying because apparently I'm
lying about all of this despite the fact that multiple people
have seen this packet that I was putting together. But everybody
says I'm lying about this on Jessica server. >> You You
understand this makes you look way worse, right? I put everything
together to catch the international trafficker. But because Pixie
sued me, I can't do it anymore. I can't send that information
to the cops. I can't do it.
It makes things look so much worse, dude. because that's fine
cuz these people are all subhuman. But the initial firm that
I was working for in uh New York was going to be plaintiff work
to go against the person who leaked
So he says plaintiff work I guess I is that not um is plaintiff
that would be plaintiff still right?
What is it in uh in criminal court? Is it plaintiff? Is it the
state? I don't think there's a plaintiff in criminal court, right?
Like wouldn't he be basically trying to get the government to
go for charges? I thought he was taking this to the FBI. >> As
soon as the defense work started, the plaintiff case took a back
not a backseat. I just I asked it because I can't afford psychologically
or monetarily to run two huge I can't afford psychologically
to go after the child trafficker. I can't psychologically afford
it.
Bro, what?
Bro, huh,
brother? What? I can't psychologically
handle
taking the information I have about Solo to the cops. I can't
psychologically handle saying, "Hey, cops, this guy's an international
trafficker. Um, I need I want to go get his information so that
you guys could pursue him, but you guys have to do something
so I can so you can get a subpoena. I need I need the like his
name, his stuff, and my payment processor." Incredible. Well,
hold on, Tequila Sunset. It's not even just that people are buying
it. It's that people he is admitting that he has more information
to go after Solo just like he had more information to find Rose
and he didn't want to do that until at some point I think people
started believing the 17-year-old thing and then he decided that
he was going to dox Rose like publicly. He couldn't make the
10-minute call Willie Mack did. Willie Mack is a bigger man.
Well, I I hope Willie Mack like I hope Willie Mack understands
that these court proceedings like have just proven that he was
correct. Everything Willie Mack said and did was correct. Well,
except maybe making the video. I assume that would be a bad call.
I hope he I wonder if he called the cops about it. Like I hope
he talked to the cops and said like, "Hey, I'm going to make
a video on this. I want to record this and make conduct." I don't
think he did.
I feel like the cops absolutely would say don't do that. I know
you don't have to pay for the feds to conduct the case. So, it's
just psychologically he couldn't possibly handle
going
anywhere. I guess >> lawsuits at the same time. Okay. So,
theoretically, the payment information would be available um
from the person who initially the merch was sold to, that was
a road that I was going down, but in order to get the information
from them, their legal team won't release it to me because it
includes addresses, everything else without um without a subpoena.
And since I didn't file that lawsuit yet for the New York case,
because we weren't ready to file that lawsuit yet, um I didn't
have anything there that I could use to to do legal pressure
against them. Um so, yeah. All right. number one. Um I think
he just understands that he can't draw attention. Um I I think
he just understands that he can't draw attention to himself,
bro. But it's like crazy that he is the guy with all of the info
about this dude and he blames Pixie.
What? He have the tweet yesterday. Oh, hold on. He had the tweet
yesterday about Lauren de or sorry about Pixie. Yeah. Where he
says, "Oh, her she's like abusing the justice system and helping
this guy get away." I think I just got to start like tweeting
about this again
probably.
So she says as she abuses the federal court system waste everyone's
time on a frivolous legal claim while destroying evidence with
her MAGA friend behind the scenes. We still have seen no evidence
of this. I understand his audience never wants evidence of anything
from Keles's here but
Jesus Christ man. All while covering for an international trafficker.
He is objectively the person covering for the international sex
trafficker. Right. Objectively. So again, I guess we were starting
this. I don't know where the doxing starts from my community.
Did we Did I miss some part where the doxing started from my
community? I guess I'm asking you guys. You guys might not be
able to see it as well. Right.
I I'm looking.
I I I looked. I didn't see anything.
Now, for the Destiny community, we of course have Let me go find
my tweet. Boxing. How the do we Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh, that's
why. Where? Oh, right here. Here it is,
bro. I need to start actually like cataloging this stuff so I
can pull it up faster on
I guess this these would be the logs. So, we can go put this
in Excal over here. Go put this tweet here. I need this to be
smaller. Cool.
This link in. Um, and then it would be the logs of him publishing
a bunch of private, not public personal information, personally
identifying information about Rose, like her face. In fact, the
information that was used to eventually dox her. He published
that and then he actually said, "Hey, Kiwi Farms, Kev's ability
to investigate anything is super pathetic." I thought it was
some crazy investigatorship, but now I realized it was just no
life obsessively stalking all my social media that allowed someone
to do it. easy to do when you live on permanent disability. Also,
I never said that pic posted was of me. It was a pic they sent
from their school. Supposedly, they were working on a blank blank.
Oh, this is a degree in something. And then also, one more pick.
I'm not in this one either, if you can't tell. Okay, good luck.
So, he posted multiple pictures of her, right? So, he posts,
was it two or three pictures of her? Two pictures of her and
her college and her major.
So, let's just do this. Destiny posts
two unseen pictures of Rose and
includes her
sorry includes her college major and college. Then pro proceeds
preceded proceeds. Prece proceeds proceeds to
taunt Kiwi Farms
to taunt Kiwi Farms into
doxing her further. So from there, so proceeds to taunt Kiwi
Farms into doxing her further. Why would Solo tell him her real
school and major? I don't know. Again, I the idea I get of the
relationship egregious film, although it was like a child trafficker,
was that they were more like boyfriend girlfriend doing like
uh this like running this Only Fans like together over like between
two countries,
not Only Fans, this like uh like they were selling videos and
stuff to make money, right? They wasn't at Only Fans, but they
were selling videos to make money. I think they did as like a
couple with like a component to it, right? That was that what
Destiny said was that the um
I think was that the boyfriend watched a lot of the stuff. The
boyfriend was like a which also Destiny knew a lot about their
dynamic like they
that's very very funny. Was this counterpoints to your document?
Oh, I just figured we would write stuff down.
So Destiny actually posts the two new pictures and proceeds to
taunt Kiwi
these two pictures. Uh, one of these
one of these two pictures is used by Kiwi
to
eventually bully Doc's rose.
Okay. So, and then on the KF part, it would be uses reverse
image search
plus other information from Destiny
and other sources.
Uh, well, would it even be from other sources or would it just
be from
Was other information from Destiny to
do Rose? And then I'm looking for like where my community participated
in this. Where did my community participate in this? Didn't Destiny
himself in the post Willy Max stream say she filmed content with
classmates?
That's a weird comment. That is a weird comment.
I did not know he said that. Your community always covers its
tracks.
you understand that like if you are logging a discord, you can't
actually like get rid of any of the information. You think nobody
in Destiny's community knows how to log a Discord? It's not even
difficult. Yeah, even unless I can tell you're joking, but Jesus.
Yeah, I don't know, man. Finding Finding Rose Discord was confirmed
to be real by Rose according to the court docs, too, by the way.
No.
Um because I think it's pretty obvious to me that
that would be her looking at the information that was like out
there and her just talking about like uh like basically stuff
that was leaked. I don't think she has extra information from
Destiny that that doxing that that like Rosefinding Discord group
is real. Destiny already confirmed it though. Like Destiny
Destiny literally confirmed it himself. He's confirmed it multiple
times. I kind of wonder sometimes if Destiny
loses track of his own lies and and then starts agreeing to things
like he didn't have to say he has Zolo's information. He didn't
have to say that. He didn't have to say that that that community,
sorry, the Discord group to find Rose was real. He could have
just said no, it's not real. Yeah, there there is nobody full
of hell. There is nobody who is doxed by my community. Nope.
Zero people, zero content creators. I I guess technically um
I I know of at least one person's name getting said, but that
was a couple in a meltdown relationship ending fight. So I don't
I don't know
little different, man. That's a little different. That's like
two people fighting, you know? I'm going to say your real name.
Weird stuff. Very weird stuff. Okay,
so evidence for who dox rose the Destiny community. So
has Destiny posted any additional information about her? I don't
think so. Did my community post any additional information about
her? I don't think so either. Jaw doxedite. I don't think so.
What about Paragon?
I mean, Paragon, I basically pulled up a picture of him from
my gen chat. I feel like that's probably not doxing, but hey,
you know, it is what it is, man. It is what it is. Okay. I thought
I thought there would just be more. I thought he would have more.
I think this is the only screenshot. So I guess purportedly he's
saying
emailing Rose
Rose contact details
details to Joan Peters
to
Joan Peters. I I'm guessing that is also something they're saying
is doxing which seems kind of crazy. Yeah. I don't even less.
Here's the thing. I don't know what the claims are. There are
no claims. It's just that it happens apparently. These DJs just
say, "Oh yeah, nope. Nope. It happens. I wasn't doxing a federal
crime yet." I don't
That's I'm I'm literally That might be the biggest thing is like,
"Hey, is there are there any examples of this happening from
my community except I guess there's the Odashara one. We could
go over that at some point." Well, I'm not going to go over that
again actually, but you watch Destiny go over that. like Odara
being like, "Hey, you know when you guys ban me for for like
you banned me because I was like a and then I think you have
to stop saying that I'm a I I think I think we called him like
a rapist and waiting or something cuz he would just he would
constantly defend not just like implied consent. He would constantly
defend like basically just arguing that deserve it a lot of the
time and started calling him like a rapist and waiting and he
uh he basically said if you call me that I'm going to get doxed
and swatted and and then he said he got sent a letter to his
house where they actually were saying like I'm going to hurt
you.
Someone said he ripped his patience and then he crashed the out.
Jesus Christ. That guy was out of his mind. Okay. Where was his
letter? Well, we asked him for it and he did not have it. Okay.
other significant efforts.
I don't know what else is here, bro. There's like nothing else.
Uh, well, I thought this could be a segment, but this was on
the fly. I just watched this and I'm like, wait, that's all
that's it? I think there's like some more stuff from Caab. I'm
pretty sure.
But I I just can't believe that that's it
cuz I I could I thought for sure there'd be something about a
threat. Plaintiff Jane Doe's motion to modify the scheduling
order. Plaintiff Jane Doe buying through the count threatening
in that server posting emails. This guy created justical discord
server now
>> uh this is this is another one. Hold on. >> So
that save a sexual guy in justical discord server is openly bragging
about in that server posting emails. This guy created several
email accounts and was harassing Rose was harassing her family
threatening them telling them like
>> Wait, did Cyber make several email accounts? I thought
he emailed several accounts. Cyber, are you still here? Did you
make several accounts or did you email several different accounts?
>> There's several email accounts that was harassing Rose
was harass
>> I think I think it's the opposite. I don't think he
made several email accounts, but I maybe I'm wrong. I I want
to get it correct. We should actually know the number cuz at
some point obviously that does become harassment if that were
to be happening. By his own admission he made several accounts.
I don't think so. I have two email. Yeah. So, the impression
I got was Cybo's emailing one account and then
>> uh No, alien mode. I don't I didn't think that's what
was said, but let's go let's go back to it right now.
I contact you from a Oh, from a different email, but you stopped
responding. Okay. Yes, this one is he had a second email. Oh,
wait. I see this is his other So, he probably was Oh, I get it.
So, he's messaging them from his regular email and then he switched
over to Cybo.
I got it. Yeah, I got it. Okay. Where does several come from?
Well, I'm guessing it's this one where he said, "Hey, I had emailed
you from a previous email, but I think you've blocked me." Now,
this is bad. If there was any further reaching out from this
point, that's very bad, S. But just so you know. Okay. I I totally
agree. You should not email people directly on the internet.
There isn't. Okay.
Okay. I mean, if that's the final one, then there you go.
So I said initially about the potential harassment is correct.
Sure. But I said I literally laid out the conditions for potential
harassment.
Right.
I literally said I said from the beginning that past this point
that's where it would turn into harassment. I think you could
send one final email like hey I think you got spooked. Here's
this other one. Right.
I just want to make it clear where
the lines are between these communities too. Right? So the line
for the communities is this is harassment
for Desty's community. Destiny says this is harassment. Bro,
do I have to go through like some of my replies? Should I Oh
man, I don't know, dude. The comparison between the two communities
is also insane. But no, I think once you're blocked, anything
beyond that is harassment. I
I think harassment has to be perpetual in some way. Um I think
this is a sensitive issue. I don't think there's something like
evil with this uh email. I'd say probably from the very beginning,
sending something like this, right? Sending something like this
wrong to do. Like like weird to do. You should you should never
do this as a participant in an online community, right? But I'm
I'm going to stand up business to say nope. The this one extra
email, that's where the line is. No, you don't get notified that
you're blocked via email. Oh, I see. Saba. Oh, apparently we
should pat out this segment. Give me a second. So, you were sending
her emails and basically saying take down these profiles and
then they were getting taken down and then you tried from a different
email because you weren't sure if she was get Okay. All right.
Sorry. Just Cabba said, uh, to be clear, I wasn't sure if I was
blocked because she's still taking down profiles that I was sending
in emails even though she wasn't responding. Okay. Wait, hold
on. Another very important question. Saaba, did she ever say
stop emailing me? Was there ever an overt, "Hey, stop." Okay,
fair, fair, fair, fair. So, you didn't know that you were blocked?
Okay, I got you. I got